محادثات ثلاثيه في موسكو اليوم ضمت وزراء
دفاع روسيا وتركيا وسوريا بالاضافه الى
رؤساء اجهزه الاستخبارات الثلاثه اللقاء
هو الاول بين وزيري الدفاع تركيا خلصي
اكاروس وسوريه علي عبد الله ايوب منذ
العام 2011
والمحادثات تطرقت لسبل حل الازمه السوريه
وقضيه اللاجئين من اسطنبول الاتصال مع
مراسل خاص بان كيك حسين اسد حسين اهلا بكم
ما هي المعلومات التي لديك حول هذا
الاجتماع
روتانا كما ذكرت هو الاجتماع الاول من
نوعه بين وزيري دفاع على تركيا وسوريا منذ
11 عاما وزاره الدفاع التركيه قالت ان
الاجتماع جرى باجواء ايجابيه ناقشا ملفات
مكافحه الارهاب واللاجئين
والانتقال او الحل السياسي لازمه في سوريا
هنا يقول مراقبون ان هذه ليست سوى خطوه في
طريق اطول وحلقه في سلسله همم ستتبعها
لقاءات على مستوى وزيري الخارجيه وايضا في
مرحله مقبله لقاء بين الرئيسين التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان وغيره السوري بشار الاسد
اردوغان تحدث عن هذا اللقاء مؤخرا كثيرا
يحاول البعض رابط تصريحات سابقه لياردوغان
بما جرى اليوم اردوغان تحدث عن طلبه من
الرئيس الروسي بلادي من بوتن دعما ما يخص
العمليه المحتمله في شمال السوري لذا
يتوقع كثيرون ان تكون هذه همم الخطوه وهذا
الدعم في عمليه ربما ثلاثيه او عمليه
ثنائيه مشتركه بين تركيا وسوريا في شمال
السوري في مناطق سيطره الاكراد تضمن
للنظام السوري التواجد والسيطره على هذه
المنطقه الحدوديه لتركيا ابعاد المقاتلين
الاكراد من المنطقه الحدوديه التي همم
تقول بين الحين والاخر انها ستكون عمليه
بريه في مناطق محدده عين العرب منبج
ومناطق اخرى تحت السيطره الكرديه ولكن
ايضا كثيرون يذهبون الى ان الموافقه
السوريه على عمليه من هذا النوع او الدعم
التحرك العسكري التركي سيكون مربوطا او او
سيكون له صله بملفات اخرى ليس اقلها ملف
سيطره تركيا والمعارضه التي تدعمها على
مناطق في الشمال السوري الامر هو بدايه
لمفاوضات اطول
واعقد بين الجانبين للتوصل الى تسويه هذه
تسويه ربما سيكون ختامها اللقاء بين
الرئيسين التركي والسوري حسين اسد مراسل
فرانس